former Catholic priests pleaded guilty
to sexual abuse charges involving two
boys David Polson faces up to 14 years
in prison for incidents that happened
between 2002 and 2010 he's one of only
two Pennsylvania priests to face charges
since a grand jury report identified
hundreds of abusive clergy yesterday the
Pennsylvania State Senate declined to
vote on a bill that would extend the
statute of limitations allowing
childhood sex abuse victims to sue Nicki
batiste spoke with two victims who
handled the issue a different way they
met face to face with the priest they
say sexually abused them this is a story
you'll only see on CBS News Nicki good
morning good morning the priests
declined our request for an interview
but because the victims told us they
wanted their conversation recorded we
set up hidden cameras they say they want
survivors and the public to hear what
their alleged abuser has to say now hi
Nicki batiste with CBS News this former
priest wasn't interested in talking with
CBS nothing nothing you want to say to
your victims you don't want to apologize
but our cameras were rolling minutes
earlier when George Qahhar cheek faced
two of the men who say he molested them
as boys
nearly four decades ago here in
Johnstown Pennsylvania cohort chick was
teaching and coaching sports at a
Catholic Reed school is this around the
age the abuse began yeah that's when he
took an interest in a pair of
ten-year-old friends
Sean Daugherty and Brian Sabo this is
the first time you're talking about your
story publicly what's the process that
got you to this point I think just this
support family my wife just constantly
reassure me I haven't done anything
wrong we were confused
I mean he's the priest not that any
other adults that your age would bathe
you in a shower but he did it like in a
joking way let me get your back you know
so there's certain things that you just
keep private but they wanted everything
to be public now as they contacted
cohort chick to arrange a sit-down what
does he hope to gain from meeting Sean
and I after all these years I hope it's
not to ask for forgiveness you know I
don't think a soul could be saved now is
there any part of you that forgives him
I know I forgive him if he's willing to
you forgive him
I forgiving him a lot of time ago so for
you or is that for him I think both it I
think tonight is for me how you doing
have a seat as they met face to face
with the admitted child abuser both had
plenty of questions at any point
when you first started having those
feelings did you feel like should I talk
to someone or must have to say between
where you got to call the bishop up and
say goodbye because then you run the
risk
was there something else about Shawn and
I that made us a target familiarity
maybe both in the things that we're
going on with the church is this
something that you would have confessed
anything look do you think that's
forgiven you
bucco heart tick claimed he didn't know
who in the church may have been aware of
his behavior good transcript for
sexually abusing kids I don't think I
felt like there was a lot of dancing
dancing feeling he just would not admit
that there's any kind of cover-up at all
how are you feeling good yeah that was
hard
I was really hard I came here not
knowing what to expect but when I wake
up tomorrow morning I'm gonna feel
really glad I did this
relieved yeah I got a lot off my chest
that I never thought that I'd get off my
chest and I just successfully met with
the guy that abused me and got to say
everything that I wanted to say to him
he got it off my chest and I'm at peace
right now I'm completely at peace in
2015 George Coe heart chick admitted to
sexually abusing several children during
a grand jury investigation he was
defrocked but never criminally charged
and the statute of limitations has
expired for his victims in Pennsylvania
in the years after the abuse
Sean Daugherty and Brian Sabo say they
struggled emotionally but today they say
a weight has been lifted from their
shoulders and you can see the courage
that they have it's remarkable courage
and you can still see the pain after all
this and when you look at their little
faces - from back in the day to where
they are today and to look at the
priests who didn't seem to have a lot of
remorse
I'm curious Nicki how you were able to
record him so we spoke with the priest
and he didn't want to speak on camera he
did want to speak with Brian and Shawn
they wanted to speak to him they
insisted it be recorded it was the only
way they would do it it was a public
place so that's what maybe I've never
seen anything like I haven't had never
seen anything like it was really is
amazing work okay Shawn and Brian hope
it helps all the victims that are out
running it seemed to help them seem to
help them it did you can hear more from
Nicki on today's CBS this morning
podcast where she shares where the idea
to confront the former priest came from
you can hear it on apple's podcast app
or wherever you download your podcasts